estamos en madrid en el prado y estamos
contemplando un velázquez de gran
formato la fragua de vulcano de hecho
algunos historiadores la han descrito
como una especie de parodia a la
izquierda está apolo el dios del sol y
de la poesía y habla con vulcano que
está forjando una armadura y todo el día
ha trabajado muy duro y apolo viene a
decirle que ve no su esposa está
teniendo una aventura con marte el dios
de la guerra solo mira la actitud de
esas dos caras
olvídate por un momento de los demás
aspectos de la pintura la espalda de
apolo es tarqueada su cabeza muy erguida
de hecho se ve como muy orgulloso
mientras le da volcano ese impactante
mensaje busca no parece horrorizado y
tiene un aspecto temible con una mano
sostiene un pedazo de metal al rojo vivo
y en la otra lleva un martillo es como
si estuviese listo para golpear
cualquier cosa pero también puedes
admirar su cuerpo tiene un torso hermoso
los músculos los huecos de las costillas
el abdomen pero su rostro tiene algo de
caraballo y ese cuerpo ideal y hermoso
de hecho todas las figuras tienen esos
cuerpos ideales como si velas que se
intentará reproducir la escultura griega
y romana a los artistas del renacimiento
quizás a miguel ángel y también el arte
de caraballo aunque las cabezas un
diferente es verdad no están tan
idealizadas de hecho son increíblemente
naturalistas aún cuando están pintadas
de manera bastante suelta entonces hay
un conflicto entre esta clase de
realismo terrestre de las figuras y lo
que están haciendo los gestos y las
emociones que transmiten pero también
dan la sensación de que están de pie
como esculturas clásicas y sus cuerpos
parecen esculturas clásicas pero por
otra parte no creo que los franceses o
los italianos hubiesen representado un
tema mitológico tan importante con este
espíritu casi de comedia verdad mira la
segunda figura de la derecha parece muy
asombrado es absurdo esta especie de
sentido de conflicto y humor está en
humanos
cierta manera es muy degradante en
realidad no un reloj clásico con el
tratamiento habitual que se le suele dar
sin embargo al mismo tiempo parece un
ejercicio académico pues tenemos a las
tres figuras masculinas en el centro
presentadas desde diferentes ángulos la
de la izquierda vulcano esta vista de
frente la siguiente desde atrás las dos
siguientes están de perfil y la última
que sin lugar a dudas se acerca hacia
nosotros y las primeras tres figuras
casi femeninas como las tres gracias se
ve muy ordenado con sentido de
composición y equilibrio y quizá un poco
como una exhibición para futuros mecenas
puesto que velásquez está aquí todavía
relativamente joven ha viajado a roma
instancias de rubens y tal vez está
demostrando sus habilidades como artista
que puede pintar desnudos masculinos
indudablemente muestran un artista que
busca reinventar o traspasar las
fronteras de cómo se cuentan las
historias